you know a few weeks ago I traveled all
the way up to Cornell and I I thought
I'd get more of that kind of crazy
welcome at Cornell than I would here uh
but I didn't I didn't H Cornell and
Vanderbilt however do have something in
common what they have in common is that
they have both been at the center of
widely reported racial hate crime hoaxes
kind of a dubious distinction to have
but they both have it uh Cornell was the
site of the most infamous uh campus hate
crime hoax probably ever this was 50
years ago when black activists burned a
cross in front of their own Student
Center to justify a takeover of a
building an armed takeover with rifles
uh at Vanderbilt the racial hate hoax
took place in the less distant past some
of you might remember it it was eight
years ago
2015 uh the national headlin said that
there was a racial hate crime consisting
of a bag of
excrement discovered on the footsteps of
the black Cultural Center on campus a
black student group called hidden doors
quickly denounced the unsavory bag as a
vile act they claimed quote the
violation of a place that in many ways
is the sole home for black students is
deplorable as many of us sit in grief
recognize that these types of actions
are what we speak of when we note the
reality of exclusion isolation of
students of color specifically black
students on campus as we announced
yesterday and reaffirmed today we will
not be
silent they are never silent they are
there is no you can call the left-wing
activists a lot of things silent is not
one of them now unlike at Cornell in the
1960s Vanderbilt in 2015 had security
cameras all over the campus when the
University Police checked the security
camera footage to investigate the
alleged hate crime they discovered that
no such crime had occurred at all
instead a blind student had used a
baggie to clean up after her guide dog
and uh then because she was not aware of
where all the trash cans were on campus
Because she was blind uh she left it on
a a stoop and decided not to bring the
bag with her into the
building this incident is an almost
perfect analogy for racial grievance the
only way it could have been more perfect
would have been if she had cleaned up
after her bull instead of her dog but it
was pretty close it was pretty good in
any case I did not come here tonight to
talk about excrement Bine K9 human any
of it I came here to talk about a deeper
issue at the heart of so much racial
debate and that is
colonialism the activist left from
Hollywood wood to the newsrooms
especially on campus has spent nearly
two months now smearing all of History's
Victors as colonizers settlers the
reason for this uptick in anti-colonial
rhetoric is hamas's current war with the
state of Israel which the left has
accused of engaging in settler
colonialism the most prominent defense
of the modern Israeli State thus far has
been to deny its status as a settler
Colonial entity this I believe is a bad
strategy for a few reasons first because
the Israeli state manifestly is a
settler and Colonial Endeavor deriving
from the B4 Declaration of the British
Empire during World War I after which
the Brits rested the territory from the
Ottoman Empire two more relevant to all
of us because our own nation is
similarly a set and Colonial project
deriving from the Treaty of Paris in
which also the British Empire recognized
the United States as an independent
nation three because all regimes in
history have been established by
settlers and colonizers of one kind or
another not since Adam in the Garden of
Eden have any people sprouted out of the
ground and Adam you might recall had a
little bit of help in the process as
well borders Nation
regimes have changed for all of history
as people have multiplied shrunk and
moved around the aim of the
decolonization activists is to return
Land from the people who currently
possess it to the people who previously
possessed
it that does not seem to me to solve the
problem that seems only to push the
problem a little bit further back in
history in 1980 the US Supreme Court
ruled that the the American government
had illegally taken the Black Hills of
South Dakota the site of Mount Rushmore
from the Lakota sue the court ordered
the government to pay the Lakota the
initial offering price of the land plus
interest coming out to a total of $16
million the US had pledged in the treaty
of fort laramy in
1868 to set the Black Hills apart quote
for the absolute and undisturbed use and
occupation of the Indians thus ending
red clouds War 6 years later however
General kuster entered the Black Hills
amid reports of gold that was found
there and after kuster's reports came
out there came the settlers they were
enticed by Cutler's reports of the land
and the resources to be found on the
land now initially the US military tried
to stop the settlers they wanted to
honor the treaty but the settlers kept
coming so president us Grant told the
military to stand down and stop opposing
the settlement eventually with so many
Americans on the land the US government
decided the only way to avoid another
war was to buy the land from the Lakota
Sue negotiations broke down general
kuster led a charge some of you who took
history classes might remember the
charge did not go very well uh he was
opposed by Sitting Bull and Crazy Horse
they defeated kuster at the famous
battle of the Little Big Horn the
victory did not last long
the Americans uh quickly defeated the
Rowdy Sue and still the Sue refused to
surrender but the Sue also didn't have
any means to survive they had been
stripped of their weapons and their
horses so in 1876 Congress made Aid to
the Sue contingent on their seeding the
land to the United States finally
putting an end to the problem some Sue
leaders agreed to a settlement but not
enough to satisfy the requirements of
the fort laramy treaty which which led
to the Supreme Court case a century
later the liberal Supreme Court ruled in
favor of the Sue in 1980 over the
objections of the conservative Justice
William ranquist notice however the
court did not say that the US government
had to give the land back to the Sue
that would have been insane for one and
it would have been completely
impractical a quarter million Americans
lived on the land it was American land
four US presidents have their faces
carved into the side of the mountain the
land is not going back anytime
soon even the Sue did not accept the
decision they had not waited over a
hundred years to accept what they
considered to be blood money for stolen
Land by 2011 the settlement was valued
at over $1
billion the Sue still would not accept
it I might have caved a little bit a
billion dollars I might have said okay
you can have the
mountains today can you imagine that was
2011 today that number is probably
somewhere in the neighborhood of a
gazillion dollars when you factor in Joe
Biden's
inflation still the Sue they hold firm
they won't accept it it's a lucky thing
that they won't because the settlement
would raise just as many problems as it
solved the reason for that is that the
Lakota Sue did not magically Sprout Out
of the Black Hills of South Dakota in
fact the Lakota Sue only possessed the
Black Hills for about a hundred years
less time in fact than the United States
has possessed it the Lakota only
acquired the Black Hills in 1776 and the
way they acquired it was by moving in
from Minnesota and conquering the
Cheyenne so should the US government pay
a billion dollars to the Lakota because
we took Lakota land or should we pay a
billion dollars to the Cheyenne because
the Lakota took cheyen
land well hold on hold on just a second
here
I think you probably see where this is
going the Cheyenne it turns out they did
not Sprout out of the ground either the
Cheyenne only moved in during the 18th
century before that the land had
belonged to the kioa and the crow before
the oji Indians started taking Land from
the Lakota impelling the cheyen to start
taking Land from the kioa and the crow
before the Lakota came in and took the
land from the Cheyenne before the US
took the land from the
Lakota wow I'm dizzy how exactly do the
anti-colonial activists suggest that we
decolonize the Black Hills I'm not
asking this just to own the libs I think
the libs have all been escorted out of
the lecture hall I'd love an answer I
would love an answer I'm all ears we're
going to have a long Q&A if anyone has
an answer to how exactly we're going to
decolonize that land I'm open to
it what are we supposed to do the right
of Conquest has been a universally
recognized principle of politics
everywhere on Earth for all of human
history until about 70 years ago when
liberal utopians pretended that a couple
of un declarations could fundamentally
change politics and human nature and
freeze history in place today we are
witnessing in real time the futility of
such pipe
dreams put the current war in the Middle
East aside this is the time of year that
the issue of decolonizing ation often
crops up and that is because we've just
celebrated
Thanksgiving some of us have celebrated
Thanksgiving I have celebrated
Thanksgiving some people don't you don't
like that lady in the front row she
doesn't like
Thanksgiving there one there at least
one more left in the people who left
this room I think don't celebrate
Thanksgiving I do I do in fact I
celebrate it for a personal reason which
is that a number of my ancestors were
present on the Mayflower and therefore
at the very first Thanksgiving this
would not be on the Italian side of my
family which my mother used to say came
here on a sardine boat but on the
English side of my family they made it
on the Mayflower one of them was a
pilgrim first doctor in Plymouth Dr
Samuel Fuller the other ones were
considered somewhat less upstanding in
the colony one of my ancestors John
Billington is the first man executed for
murder in the Plymouth Colony his friend
uh Francis Eaton uh was a man with a lot
of financial problems he died a debtor
and then my final Mayflower ancestor
Steven Hopkins was so Infamous a
mutineer that his shipwreck around
Bermuda on the sea Voyage served as the
basis for Shakespeare's Tempest so it
was a little bit of a mixed bag with the
ancestors does that mean that I will
disavow my
ancestors no no far from it I actually
just launched a Cigar Company in honor
of my my ancestors called Mayflower
cigar cigars oh thank
you I wish I see a cigar in the front
row from my friend I wish that I had
some uh Mayflower cigars for you all we
actually sold out in the first day we we
had a four-month stock oh thank you it
was 30,000 cigars we sold out in the
first day in any case I what how did I
get on that oh right I don't disavow my
ancestors that's how and I don't disavow
my biological ancestors for the same
reason that we should not devow our
political ancestors men such as
Christopher Columbus the founding
fathers all the Great Men Who Built our
nation namely because without them we
would not be here we stand on the
shoulders of giants and the stupid ones
Among Us think that they are
flying why did our ancestors literal and
political settle this land why did they
colonize this farflung place the
decolonization activists will tell you
they did so for material plunder as
usual these liberal accusations are in
fact confessions the libs are projecting
as they often do having adopted the
fashionable materialism of modernity
these leftists cannot even imagine that
one might be motivated by higher ideals
but in the case of the great men of
history that we are discussing Columbus
the pilgrims The Fanny fathers they were
and the proof of that is that none of
them got particularly Rich for their
troubles in fact most of them were
personally impoverished Christopher
Columbus was never paid what he was owed
by the Spanish Crown in fact part of the
reason they accused him of all sorts of
bogus crimes is is to get out of paying
him what he was owed that's a lecture
for another day uh in as much as
Columbus did undertake that perilous
voyage for wealth he did so in order to
fund a crusade to retake the Holy Land
as Carol Lany details very well in her
her book on the subject the pilgrims of
the Mayflower gave up not one but two
lives of relative Comfort one in England
and another one in Leiden in the
Netherlands which was their adopted home
after they got to America half of them
died before the first winter was through
George Washington lost half of his net
worth in the revolution John Adams faced
major financial problems throughout the
war problems that he could have fixed
had he not continued to serve in the
Continental Congress Thomas Jefferson
died a dtor and that debt grew in large
part due to his 40 Years of public
service for virtually all of history
everywhere on Earth mere acquisitiveness
sufficed to justify Wars of Conquest but
ironically the men that the leftists
call thieves and plunderers were all
motivated by higher ideals up to and
including the highest ideal of all
religion the worship of and service to
God the s
Colonial dispute in the Middle East
today is obviously religious just as the
settling of America was religious just
as all human conflict to cite Cardinal
Manning is ultimately
religious sometimes the religious tenor
of these conquests led to gross
Injustice as we see in the case of the
Aztec empire which sacrificed the
peoples that it conquered to the demons
that it worshiped just 5 years before
these supposedly evil colonizers
Christopher Columbus sailed the ocean
blue the Aztec sacrificed more than
880,000 people at the consecration of
the Temple of tenoch tlon over the
course of just four days hernand Cortez
another supposedly evil colonizer
witnessed these precise sorts of
sacrifices when he arrived in 1521 to
the capital of Teno Tian where the Aztec
priests sliced open the chests of
sacrificial victims and offered their
still beating Hearts as a sacrifice to
the demons before tossing ing their dead
bodies down the steps of the
temple not very nice we don't you would
not like that kind of colonialism now
happily Cortez conquered the Aztecs he
stopped the human sacrifice he ended the
demon worship and he introduce the
natives to Christianity all good news
the Liberals consider this a very bad
thing the Liberals don't seem to have
much of a problem with demons they even
speak like demon the way they use these
pronouns now my name is Legion for we
are many there are a lot of
eerie similarities they don't seem to
have a problem with it they dress up
like demons at concerts all the weird
Sam Smith stuff you know they do all
these kinds of strange New Age rituals
with the crystals and the Woo Woo You
know it's where they it's weird it's
weird man they don't have a problem with
that they don't have a problem with
human sacrifice either as shown by their
now sacramental stance on abortion but
those of us who oppose Human Sacrifice
be it on it be it rather on the demonic
alars of Teno tlon or of Planned
Parenthood tend to consider the end of
Aztec rule to be unambiguously a
positive
development there will after all be
Conquest people will grow shrink and
move so if there will be Conquest it
seems preferable that such Conquest be
Christian rather than demonic the kind
of imperialism that builds Sant croche
rather than tenoch titlan the sort of
Conquest that teaches people to love
their enemies rather than to rip their
hearts out an additional advantage of
Christian
conquest is that uh it imposes certain
restrictions on the conquerors unlike
many other religions notably Islam
Christianity has almost never spread by
the sword I say almost because there are
two exceptions to that in the case of
char leag who I will note had a
theological adviser Alin of York who
urged him not to spread the Faith by the
sword uh and also later on in Spain but
the reason that Christianity has
virtually never spread by the sword is
because of this fun fact about
Christianity which is that for a
conversion to be valid it has to be
undertaken freely the early Christians
made Disciples of all Nations not by
threatening to kill them but by being
killed themselves hence trellian
observation in the 2 Century that the
blood of the martyrs is the seed of the
church throughout the ages the church
consistently insisted upon protections
for conquered and colonized peoples when
the Conquistadors got a little bit
high-handed with the natives in the
early 16th century Catholic missionaries
complained to the Pope Paul III who
issued the apostolic brief pastoral
pastoral officium reminding The
Conquistadors that the Holy Roman
Emperor Charles I had already forbidden
the enslaving and robbing of the natives
and further threatening anyone who
continued to transgress with the
ultimate punishment which would be
automatic
excommunication in it is ironic that the
decolonization activists Focus their ire
exclusively on the west what was once
called Christendom not only is the West
not uniquely or even especially
responsible for the evils of
Conquest the West in fact has been
uniquely innocent of the crimes
associated with Conquest if the growth
shrinking and movement of peoples is
inevitable that is to say if Conquest is
an inescapable fact of
politics then who would you rather be
conquered by would you rather be
conquered by Christians or
Aztecs Christians or jihadis Christians
or atheists we haven't even touched on
the atheists yet The Atheist regimes
which are responsible for the worst
crimes associated with Conquest in the
20th
century I sometimes tell critics of
Christian nationalism that if they think
Christian nationalism is bad just wait
until they unchristian
nationalism the same is true of
settlement colonialism and
Conquest if you believe that the Western
kind of Conquest is bad just wait until
you see all the other kinds